- Good morning, BelieveNation.
Today's message is: look beyond rules.
Over to you, Nicolas Cage.
(a rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I try to see myself as somebody that
is interested in extremes.
That is interested in
maybe breaking boundaries,
in terms of what is considered
acceptable or not acceptable to do.
I don't like the idea of
rules in art (laughs),
I once said a long time,
- That's one place where you
don't find a lot of rules.
- Yeah, and, uh,
I once said, I think in a magazine,
that to be a good actor,
you have to be something of a criminal.
Of course, they took that as, like,
I wanted to be a criminal.
Which isn't true.
I just, I just think that you,
you need to look beyond rules.
- I think this is really, really, really,
really, really important.
You need to understand
that rules are created for people who
have below average skills at something.
If you think about
a classroom that you went to,
maybe you went to university,
to college, or high school,
and you're sitting in the class,
you got 20, 50, 100, 500 people
sitting there with you,
the material is designed
to teach the below average person.
At that skill set.
Right?
It's designed so that
almost everybody can get it.
And, as a result, the pace is so slow
that if you're really good at that stuff,
you're bored.
And a lot of you who've
been through those classes,
know what I'm talking about.
Where, if you went,
and talked to the professor, the teacher,
the person who's teaching the material,
and you sat down with them for an hour,
you'd learn way, way, way, way more
because it's customized to you.
And the same principle
applies to your life.
And it applies to your business.
Understand that most of the rules
that you're paying attention to
in your life and your business,
were designed
for the below average
person at that skill level.
And if all you do,
is follow the rules,
follow the way that
everybody else does it,
you're going to have a
below average experience.
If you just sell the same product
for the same price,
and you have the same marketing,
have the same website,
if you're just copying somebody else,
and just following the rules,
you're going to have a
below average experience.
What you need to do,
with that example of
talking to the professor,
where you customize the experience,
you need to apply that same principle
to your life and your business, as well.
You need to think,
how do I customize
my life, and my business,
to make it suit me?
So I can have the greatest value,
and the greatest impact,
on the people around me.
On my customers,
on my community,
on the world.
You need to figure out ways
to customize what you do
so that it fits you,
your unique talents,
your unique gifts,
and you can't do it by
following the rules.
If you look at every successful business,
in history,
go look them up,
who ever you look up to,
whatever the company
is that you look up to,
whatever entrepreneur it
they did not follow the rules.
They did things in their own way,
and they paved a new path,
instead of being a sheep
and following the existing path.
That's what you need to do for yourself.
You cannot bring yourself down,
to the below average standards.
Now that doesn't mean you have to go
and break all rules, right?
Some rules, you know, you're
going to get in trouble
if you break, right?
If you are speeding, you're
going to get a ticket,
you got to deal with that.
There are other rules that have
much bigger consequences as well.
But very few of the rules that
you currently feel are important,
actually are.
And what you need to do is think about
how do I take my genius,
my talent,
what I'm really, really good at,
and apply that to this industry
in a way that it's never been done before?
Other sheep are out selling it this way,
this is how they market,
this is how they sell,
this is how they promote.
If you're not good at that,
if that's not driving you,
if you can't be the best
in the world at that,
forget that.
Who cares if that works in that industry?
Who cares if that's the traditional way
everybody else is selling?
Let them play out here.
You're going to come over here.
You're going to do this thing
that only you can do,
that you can be the best in the world at,
that get people excited about,
that nobody's ever done before,
that's what you're going to do.
That's how you're going to stand out.
That's how you're going to win customers.
That's how you're going to feel happy.
That's how you're going to feel fulfilled.
That's about being you.
Bringing your genius, your talent,
your abilities, your
excitement, your passion
to your industry
in a way that's never been done before.
You have to do it if
you want to stand out.
You have to do it if you
want to have a big impact.
You can't just follow the rules.
Rules are great guidelines to start with.
It's good to know, in general,
how something is working.
It's good to know where some
of the penalties are.
But don't let that shackle you
in that this is the only way to do it.
You need to understand,
and then go out and do your own thing.
This is why I love modeling success.
Because, when you model success,
when you look at people
in a different industry,
look at any entrepreneur
that you look up to,
if you are in the car business,
you can go learn from
a Steve Jobs,
or Oprah Winfrey,
or Martha Stewart,
someone who's totally
outside the industry.
You can take something that worked
for Howard Schultz, who started Starbucks,
and apply to your chair
manufacturing business.
In a way that nobody's
ever done it before.
And it feels like you, you're this
pioneer trailblazer
breaking all the rules,
when it's just learning from somebody else
who's done it in a different industry.
But you're not going to have success
as a chair manufacturer
doing what all the other
chair manufacturers are doing.
It's not going to work.
You're going to end up with
below average results.
Customize your life,
and your business,
to the genius that you have inside.
Express yourself.
Let it come out.
Let it fulfill you.
Let your audience feel it.
Let your customers feel it.
Let the media feel it.
That's where your success
is going to come from.
Financial success,
emotional success,
personal success,
that's where it's going to come from.
Stop paying attention to the rules.
As Steve Jobs famously said,
"You'll discover, at some point,
"that the rules are designed by people
"who are no smarter than you."
And so why are you living your life,
running your business,
according to other people's expectations?
According to what other people
say you need to do?
Instead of letting this gift,
this art,
come out and dominate.
So the question of the day, today, is:
I want to know, what are the rules
that you're breaking in your industry,
or in your life?
Super curious to find out.
Leaving the comments below,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Sheri,
from optisourcebook.com.
Sheri, thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book, Your One Word,
it really, really,
really means a lot to me.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot
of #Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
So, for the past few months,
I've been getting a lot
of comments on my videos,
and people asking me,
am I related to Nicolas Cage?
I look a lot like Nicolas Cage.
And, to me, this is just
totally ridiculous.
Because everybody looks like Nicolas Cage.
And I have the proof to back it up.
Pregnant women look like Nicolas Cage.
Your rib cage looks like Nicolas Cage.
E.T. looks like Nicolas Cage.
Gandolf,
Yoda,
Hillary Clinton,
Little Mermaid,
Mona Lisa,
Bill Clinton,
Albert Einstein,
the Statue of Liberty,
Biggie,
Buzz Lightyear,
Princess Leia,
the Green Lantern,
Miley Cyrus,
Barack Obama,
everybody looks like Nicolas Cage.
I don't know why you guys would say that,
but I'm deeply hurt.
I'm taking names.
And I'm going to remember who you are.